hi guys welcome to my first episode of
super Sicilian tournament traps where we
are going to witness some high profile
traps which you can use in the
tournament practice as a complete
surprise weapon
[Music]
in today's lecture we are going to look
at the dragon mail line and the critical
position arises after the following
opening mortar
E4 C5 Knight to F3 D6 D4 C captures D4
Knight captures D4 Knight to F6 Knight
to C3 and now the trademark Dragon move
G6
okay the main line continues with
Bishop to E3
Bishop to G7
F3
black castles on the king side
and here we have a parting of the way
the old mail line start with Bishop to
C4 however nowadays
it has been completely vanished and at
GM level white is exclusively playing
the move Queen to D2 where the idea is
very obvious
Castle on the Quinn side and become
Hallows on the king side
okay so let's see how black is going to
counter this Knight to C6
Castle on the queen side
and in my dirty chess tricks against
Sicilian part 18 I have shown why D5 is
not a good move here
so instead of this I recommend you
should start with Bishop to D7
and after G4
continue with Rook to C8
well more or less white don't bother
about Blackmore so he continues assault
on the king side with H4 and after our
Knight to E5
what else but H5
touching down the black side
now pay the attention as black plays
Queen to A5 and we have reached to the
most critical position of the Dragon
main line
just stop for a moment and look at the
database
King B1 has been highestly played here
and the reason is very obvious
in some lines black might threaten Rook
capture C3 and then take on A2 something
which white has to look out all the time
so the answer is very obvious
why not play King to B1 and diffuse all
the black thread so that y can continue
on the king side assault
and at first sight it looks pretty good
except one problem that white has
straight away fallen into one of the
most high profile trap in the dragon
main line
now before I move on I like you to pause
this video and find out a killer move
here which completely Bamboozled the
white Cam
are you ready did you find this amazing
shot
Knight takes F3
what a move well to be honest first time
when I have seen this move I thought
hang on what is going on
black is giving up the piece for what
well that is you are going to witness
soon
here white has no choice he has to take
this Knight
and after this it doesn't look like
black has anything going on except
grabbing some Pawns
but if you are amazed by Black's last
move you will be absolutely thrilled
by Black's next dazzling reply
just look at those guys Rook capture C3
boom
another Super dazzling sacrifice
and I'm sure if white has seen this
position first time he is really going
to scratching his head wondering what's
going on
okay so the first thing first
let me turn on the database and the
obvious question you asking is why can't
why take this Rook with the queen
as he is a clear Rook ah
and surprisingly enough black is
exchanging the queen
and after this it doesn't look like
black shouldn't continue the game but
chess is sometimes a very funny game
and after Black's next reply that is
Bishop captures G4 now you will see the
potential of this lie
we have some forcing moves as the F3
Knight is hanging so by far the most
popular choice is Bishop to E2 defending
the Knight
and after this yet another Pawn goes
down to the drain with Knight captures
E4 and don't forget this move comes with
a thread that is Knight capture C3
something which white need to address
immediately
when first time I analyze this position
I was really shocked that if you look at
the database Bishop to D4 has been
highestly played here
but in fact this is the big time blunder
by white as just one move
E5 and whitens completely losing
the majority of the games in the
database continues with Bishop takes A7
but after the killer sequence Knight to
C3 check
into Sivan Knight takes e to check King
to D2 and finally when black grabbed the
Knight if you count the material
suddenly black has three pawns and two
minor pieces against a lonely Rook which
is obviously
close to winning Advantage for the black
okay so let's look at some serious
approach to defend this threat
the second move I want to consider is
Rook to D3 and White's idea is after
Knight capture C3 he want to sack The
Exchange
to remove that thread
but look at the final position after
Bishop takes E3 Pawn takes G6 and Edge
captures G6 if you count the material
black has four connected pass phone for
a piece which is obviously in terms of
practical play a huge advantage and if
you look at the database here the
majority of the games favors the black
so this is what we are going to achieve
if white played accurately up till the
20th move of the game
last but not least probably the most
accurate responses Bishop to D2
defending the threat and White's idea is
that you cannot play Knight to F2 as
Rook to G1 is a very strong reply
okay so that means black response is
forced he has to take on C3 with the
bishop and after this the forcing
accurate sequence continue with Bishop
to F6 counter attacking the black Rogue
now I really don't like what black has
been playing so far that is Rook to C8 I
think after this white obtained a
slightly better position
so rather than going for the bad move I
strongly insist you should continue with
Bishop to F6
where yes you are ready to sacrifice
your Rook but you have also your own
threads going on
first of all let's see what happens if
white accept the Rook which I think
already a bad move because after Knight
to C3 King to C1 Knight takes E2 King to
D2 and Bishop to F3
we more or less get same kind of idea
that is Bishop to F6
Knight to C3 attacking both the rook and
when white save one of them we can
simply Chop It Off
and at the end result if you count the
material this time around we have again
the same scenario
four pawns against a single piece and
most importantly if you look at the
engine Evolution it clearly favors the
black
last but not least white can also
decline our Rook offer and continue with
Rook to D3 which is in fact happen in
very high profile video games where
after this black simply played Rook to
C8 and get a winning advantage
in fact the game finished very quickly
Knight to D2 has been played
black played Bishop to F5
and in the view of double thread white
decided to sack the exchange with Knight
takes E4 Bishop takes E4 Rook to even
but after Bishop takes Rook takes
B6
and when white exchanged the pawn at the
G6
once again if you count the material we
have four Pawn advantage against the
lonely Bishop and I can definitely
assure you in terms of practical point
of view this is huge for black as only
chess engine can defend such a situation
from the white
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this high profile trap in the
dragon main line
remember when your opponent played the
most popular move King to B1
give him this double Shock first Knight
captures F3 and then this lovely Rook
sacrifice
which even though exchanged the Queen
the end result after Bishop G4 Bishop E2
and Knight captures E4
clearly favors the black
there are a bunch of title players has
fallen for the strap so you can
literally use it as a complete surprise
weapon in your tournament practice
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and I
will see you in my next episode very
soon
bye and take care